joe biden was asked about that gallup
poll i referred to earlier
56 percent of americans say they're
better off today than they were four
years ago
he was asked about what he would say to
people who feel that way
he not not only did he not have an
answer it wasn't just that
he had the worst answer possible gallup
reported
last week 50 56 of americans said that
they were better off today
than they were four years ago would have
been under the obama binding
administration
so why should people who feel that they
are better off today
under the trump administration vote for
you well if they think that they
probably shouldn't
i'm donald trump and i approve this
message
i don't think that's an actual trump
campaign i think someone just clipped
that together on the internet but it
could be i think trump should run that
ad what do you say to people who say
they're better off under trump even with
a pandemic even with an economic
collapse they're better off under trump
than they were under you
as well i got nothing to say to him i
guess they shouldn't vote for me
wrong answer i mean it's the correct
answer it's the true answer but
politically
it's incorrect politically it's not
advantageous compare that guy
to president trump who is now he's
feeling better than ever
he goes to a rally in pennsylvania he
says he's feeling so good he
he's feeling so safe from the virus he
wants to kiss everybody
and i could have stayed in the basement
of the white house or maybe the top
floor of the white house i could have
done that but i'm the president of the
united states i can't do that
i got to get out and i have to meet
people and i have to see people and i
know it's risky to do that
but you have to do what you have to do
you know i'm the president i can't sit
in the basement and say let's wait this
thing out
i'm not going to do that and now i'm
immune they tell me i'm immune i could
come down and start kissing everybody
i'll kiss every guy man and woman man
and woman look at that guy how handsome
he is
i'll kiss him not not with a lot of
enjoyment but that's okay
i'll kiss them all the men and the women
even the men it won't be my favorite
you got to remember and we always forget
it about this guy because he's
he's pretty smooth about it this is a
showman this guy
is a comedian i mean he is a top tier
comedian he's a top-tier hollywood guy
and has been
for 30 years and i'm glad he's going out
there and doing rallies
he should be doing a whole lot more
rallies that is where he is thriving
democrats are trying to cook the debates
that's the right thing compare that
compare that guy on his feet
there was a video going around of trump
dancing the ymca
on on uh you know one of these platforms
one of these rally stages
there's no need to be unhappy he's just
he's feeling good he's feeling healthy
compare that to joe
who hasn't even had the coronavirus he
can't remember anything
you may remember i got in trouble when
we were running against
the senator who was a mormon the
governor okay
and i took him on no he is a senator he
was a governor i like that joe biden
starts this up
you may remember no you you may remember
i hope you remember because i don't
remember what were we talking about
where am i
it's joe biden that's joe biden without
coronavirus
donald trump with coronavirus much more
vigorous than joe biden without
coronavirus
speaking by the way of of uh
senator romney i mean biden has you've
seen these
he's had so many of these moments he
just recently again said that he's a
proud democrat running for the senate
you know he doesn't even remember what
office he's running for very very sad
and in the midst of this speaking of
mitt romney you have
the answer to the question that nobody
was asking romney says
here are my thoughts on the political
situation
because it's one of these stupid awful
infographics i've stayed quiet with the
approach of the election but i'm
troubled by our politics
as it has moved away from spirited
debate to a vile vituperative
hate-filled morass
that is unbecoming of any free nation
let alone the birthplace of modern
democracy
the president calls the democratic vice
presidential candidate
a monster he repeatedly labels the
speaker of the house crazy
he calls for the justice department to
put the prior president in jail
he attacks they got blah blah blah blah
blah then
he says does he ever get to the
democrats here
he does oh yes he says pelosi tears up
the president's state of the union
speech on national television
keith olbermann calls the president a
terrorist media on the left and right
amplify it all and and you know it's so
awful he even he gives the democrats and
others he says democrats launch
blistering attacks of their own
though their presidential nominee
refuses to stoop as low
as others biden he's a good guy vote for
biden is what he's really saying
these attacks are terrible they're
dangerous it's time to lower the heat
uh this guy is insufferable mitt romney
he thinks that whining makes him
virtuous
he thinks that sanctimony
makes him virtuous he thinks that
self-righteousness
makes him righteous
it doesn't this is pure cowardice
that's that's what we've got from romney
you know i voted for the guy in the
general in 2012
but in my defense i worked for two of
his uh
primary opponents i always knew romney
was like this
and and he's proving it right this is
pure cowardice
because what romney's saying is i'm a
republican but not one of those
republicans
what romney's saying is i hate the
political reality fine i think a lot of
us
hate the political reality or at least
we would prefer a different political
reality yeah i think all of us would
and he says and i'm just i'm so much
better than our politics i'm so much
better than this
i don't want to have to do this i don't
have to vote for trump he's mean
buddy there is nothing
nice and kind and virtuous about
divorcing yourself from reality and
choosing to live in fantasy
nothing at all this is where we are that
politics happens in reality it doesn't
happen in fantasy
doesn't happen in ideological manifestos
it doesn't happen
in mitt romney's pruned and gardened
wonderful walled off life it happens in
reality if you want to do anything
for us in politics you have to do it in
reality
and these thinly veiled
sort of subtle endorsements of joe biden
who would empower all of these awful
people
is is a is a cowardly low
sort of thing to do and even if even if
he would deny that even if he says no
i'm not
subtly endorsing biden which i think he
is but even if he weren't
to throw up your hands and say oh it's
all awful we've both got problems we
don't this is something that has been
pushed by the left
the left has degraded our language the
left has degraded our politics the left
has degraded our supreme court
nomination process
the left has degraded our presidential
elections by refusing to accept the
results
in 2000 in 2016 in 2017 in 2018 when
they tried to launch a coup d'etat
not successfully thankfully they have
done this
and what romney wants to say is oh we're
both bad aren't we yeah
i'm a good guy don't you like me
pathetic absolutely pathetic
so it is an embarrassment that that man
is in the u.s senate it would be so much
better
if he were not in the u.s senate and if
he gave that seat up to a conservative
who has courage which is a virtue and
it's the prerequisite
for all of the other virtues if you
enjoyed that video
and i would hope that you did please be
sure to hit the subscribe
button so that all of the befuddled
radicals
wading through the wasteland of youtube
knows
where they can get the truth thanks